where i'm from you don't do acting
you're not an actor where i'm from and i
think like after analyzing it mine comes
from a lot of pain you know i got kicked
out of drama year nine
right because i wanted to be a chris
tucker tree in the play
and my drama teacher was being a waste
man
this wasn't a one-off incident we did
romeo and juliet once yeah and she said
to me you just be a brick
and i was like
so she was a waste man and i think
really all this acting is just to prove
her wrong so miss griggs if you're out
there who's a brick now
who or what was your inspiration or
moment that made you pursue acting as a
career
very is there anyone in particular who
who
you saw and were like that's what i want
to do
no i remember i remember doing the
nativity play
and um they they
they needed a mary and no one wanted to
touch the boy's hands
because they had germ and i was like
look i'm gonna warm up i'm gonna do this
thing
it's gonna be all good and then at the
end of this and just getting applause
and i literally got addicted to applause
and i think i was just like
i love this like i love the sort of i
love
um an audience response and i think
that's and then i started sort of
finding actors that i loved and fell in
love with but yeah that's
it was mary that made me wonder the
third the virgin mary is your music
much like many renaissance painters
before you um
yourself who is that who who did you see
that sort of set you on the path to
becoming a brilliant
comedy actor um i don't know about
brilliant company
but i i am uh when i was a kid i watched
fred astaire
and i would go around my flat
my parents flat in my socks acting like
i was um
some fantastic type dancer and i kind of
i'm just thinking of you like
like um tom cruise in risky business or
whatever it is
just imagine imagine a six-year-old
doing that's exactly what it was
yeah and it's exactly what it was no but
the the the decision i made was i
saw i we took a trip to
stratford-upon-avon from morocco
with my school and we watched uh
production henry v
and ian glenn played henry v and he
swung out
and over the audience what looked like
over the audience
on a big chain for the sort of uh close
the wall up with her english dead speech
and i was just like
i'm gonna do this yeah it was a big
pyrotechnics and everything and it was
all blowing up and it was
quite special yeah that is an impressive
school trip we just went to bird world
so i'm very jealous of you jamie
who do you who was your comedy heroes
when you got into
all of this i mean all the classics
everyone knows them
i mean i suppose my dad is probably as a
kind of like origin point
like i don't know so much mad stuff
would go on in our house
sort of resembled story structure that
you sort of eventually start to go oh
and i can tell these stories people at
school and they become
it's like oh they just work i don't have
to add anything to them like i remember
my dad used to
run like a greasy spoon cafe and
uh he once came home and he was like uh
uh jamie look at the internet and find
out what was the name of the ship in the
film
the titanic
and i was like you're joking the titanic
and he was like ah
i bet bert 15 pounds is the merry rose
[Laughter]
and what are you doing but but i kind of
think stuff like that
like me and my sister would just like
die laughing and be like that's
objectively funny
there's no like there's no strength of
that we've got to try and do something
with that
yeah sean who do you who did you as a
comedy performer who do you look at and
go god they
they're just brilliant and that's
something i want to follow in their
footsteps kind of thing
i mean to be honest i didn't really i
didn't really have
um anything like that like i i grew up
doing
um amateur dramatics in my area
i mean i knew when i was like seven
years old that i wanted to be an actor
so i like i joined the uh the group and
i
um i did we did the wizard of oz i
played a munchkin
and then i got like uh right passage
and then i got stage fright so i didn't
do the show the next year but my sister
did it and they did the little mermaid
and i had this like really strong like
feeling that i can remember like it was
yesterday where i was sat in the
audience and i was watching the show
and i knew that i needed to be or i
wanted to be
on the stage and not in the audience
and then i did like loads of amazon but
i did like musical theater basically
until
i was 18. then i went to drama school
and then i was spat out into this
industry which
like completely kind of like stifled me
and wouldn't let me play character roles
or anything like that but of course
i had my little spy on a bridge there
who her intention her hard intention was
always to showcase that
that side of me so i'm just like like
genuinely like indebted to her for the
rest of my life
um but imelda staunton was someone that
i just was obsessed with
i saw her in um her and clark peters
and henry goodman and joanna riding in
guys and dolls at the national when i
was 14 years old
and then i went back and i queued from
like five in the morning to like watch
it again
twice so that was like a that was
another huge
moment where i knew i knew i wanted to
do this but imalda staunton is probably
the person that's been like consistently
someone i've i've followed but to my
shame like
comedy i'm i know nothing about like i
i'm i learned from all of these
incredible
people that i am totally in aware of um
yeah i don't know i i can't believe that
because you you
certainly don't look like that once you
look like you you nail every joke and
your timing is so perfect when you're
doing
those lines and and that's more than the
script that is so much about the
performance and
timing is impossible you can't learn
timing you either know it or you don't
but
maybe something to do with musicals i
don't know i don't know maybe yeah yeah
who did you who do you look up to or who
did you have in mind when you got into
all of this sort of comedy side of
things
got into do you know um
[Music]
uh so i didn't i i i've never played a
comedic
role before eric i'd never i'd never
played one and i'd never
thought of myself as a comedic actor
um in terms of getting into acting i it
hadn't been like a burning passion that
i had
from growing up i was like 17 in high
school couldn't decide what to do
and my teacher was like you need to go
to drama school
and not uni because you're not going to
hack you're going to you're not going to
hack uni
so i was like okay
let me try drama school thankfully i got
in thank you i loved it
um but it was mostly like classical
theater i'd never
played a comedic character and i don't
yeah i think i i find people really
funny
and i find like um i didn't like people
meet on the street really funny and i
always like take little bits
of what someone said and put them in in
terms of like
inspiration for eric i watched a lot of
there's a youtuber called grace
abdullahi
i really liked like random influences
um how do you say hello grace
how do you spell her surname
a j i l o r e
a yeah i just was obsessed
and watched a lot of that before my
audition for eric
um but in terms of influences
uh look every everything i tend to think
that everyone around me is great and i
just
steal whatever anyone else is doing and
like add them
add them to whatever i'm doing guys is
your are your comedy heroes sort of um
stand-ups
who are also actors or are they straight
up actors or who do you go to when
you're sort of looking for inspiration
yeah listen as a viewer all of those
classics from
from chapal to martin lawrence and
everything they did but like where i'm
from
you don't do acting you're not an actor
where i'm from and i think like after
analyzing it mine comes from a lot of
pain you know i got kicked out of drama
year nine
right because i wanted to be a chris
tucker tree in the play
and my drama teacher was being a waste
man
but listen this wasn't a one-off
incident we did romeo and juliet once
yeah and she said to me you just be a
brick
and i was like
maybe you're walking right now stand in
the corner and be a brick so she was a
waste man
and i think really all this acting is
just to prove her wrong so miss griggs
if you're out there
who's the brick now
miss craig's is your reason
[Music]
[Music]
you